you have media sources that you thought
were these like pristine amazing
institutions like the new york times or
the washington post or cnn or msnbc but
every single day and every single night
they're running more
articles or running more stories saying
that oh the the breaking gun uh breaking
news walls
the walls are crashing in and i'd see it
every day and like i'd turn on you know
like rachel maddow at night and i was
like holy cow like people actually
believe this and i write actually you
know schumer used to be a close friend
of our family and he was going around
the upper east side telling all my my
parents friends like jared's about to be
indicted he's going to go to jail we
know it for sure we have all the facts
what they did to collude with russia
they were basically denying an election
i'm dave rubin and joining me is a
former senior advisor to president
donald j trump and author of the brand
new book the new york times
number one best-selling book we're gonna
have to talk about that in just a second
breaking history jared kushner good to
see you my friend how's it going doing
great thank you for having me on david i
am glad to be sitting here with you
first off they put you at number one in
the new york times
i don't think the new york times likes
you very much and they did it how does
that feel because they didn't put me on
there at all for my last book so this is
a little bit of a little little tug here
you know it is funny that it's given
this height um
as a goal to attain but i think that is
the goal that all the people who are
authors try to attain so it's nice to
have achieved it but you try not to give
it too much value as well so but it was
kind of funny they wrote a review that
was pretty
uh unhinged in terms of how they
characterized the book and actually once
that happened the sales of the book
started going up immediately right and i
think it's because what's in the book
contradicts a lot of what they wrote
about trump and his administration for
four years and so they obviously didn't
want to see it in existence or want
people to read a point of view that
differs from theirs they are not big
fans of that that is for sure i do
appreciate the fact that your book
matches our local set pretty pretty
perfectly as you know i just got back on
the grid so you released the book came
out last week of august right so i did
not get to see any of your press around
this or anything
so i'm going into this pretty pretty
blind and when i've mentioned you on the
show we've gotten to know each other a
little bit personally over the last
couple months since i moved down here
and uh
when you like mention you on the show i
often say people don't know what his
voice sounds like they see him but they
don't know what his voice sounds like so
let's let's do the beginning stuff first
i'm a long island guy you're a jersey
guy we have a similar background
somewhat similar ages uh tell people a
little bit of the the jared kushner
growing up story i thought you're gonna
ask me to sing or something
with that build up so uh no it's great
and obviously it's been great having you
and and
your family down in florida now your
extended family
so basically i grew up in new jersey and
had a lot of different experiences i try
to write it very quickly in the book
right it's like doing your bitchier your
obituary in like 5 000 pages trying to
just condense it but i basically grew up
in a in a great suburb had uh you know
amazing parents and uh just write about
the journey in my life i write
about obviously you know starting
businesses in college and and whatnot
um and i write about how um
afterwards i was in law school in
business school my
um
sorry i'm not used to like nice
questions like that
you're freaking out because i'm not
trying to get you i'll get you in a
second i'm used to the killers coming at
me so yeah it's too it's too nice
um
but the uh but basically i write in the
book about my upbringing i was in law
school at nyu in business school after
graduating harvard
and i was working manhattan district
attorney's office i thought i'd be a
prosecutor and then my father got
arrested and and i realized i didn't
want to be a prosecutor anymore i kind
of saw what happens when prosecutors
have a lot of political ambition and
unchecked power and i didn't think i
could i could be in that position um
and uh and then i right through what
that experience was like how it changed
my view of the world i met a lot of
people through that experience and i
went to my father's business you know it
was a real time of of problems and you
know really through through that period
that three-year period and then the
three-year period of the financial
downturn that's where i learned a lot of
lessons that
um that that really taught me a lot and
then i write about how i was very
fortunate when i was in new york to meet
a great uh great beautiful woman named
ivanka who uh we had a interesting
courtship she she said yes which was uh
really great i got the permission from
her dad
and uh do you go to the dad first on
that one
um
so i actually give a little bit of this
story but
uh after i didn't really spend too much
time with him for about the first year
that we were dating on and off and
then we were getting serious and so
ivanka said you know my dad
you gotta go talk to him because if not
he's gonna start thinking you know
you're not interested and so i reach out
to him and i say you know hi mr trump uh
you know this is jared kushner i'm
dating ivanka i'd really like to come
over and spend some time together i
didn't know what the hell i was gonna
say yeah and he says that's great why
don't we have lunch tomorrow i'm like oh
man that's that's tough
i go over to trump tower and uh we have
lunch in the trump grill and what was
funny about him is he would never go out
for lunch so ivanka was very surprised
because he would always have lunch by
his desk or you know he didn't like to
waste the time of going out so we're
going trump grill and trump tower he's
got trump security guards around
trump napkins trump glasses trump burger
trump loaf everything so
and uh yeah i said i'm like you know
ivanka and i were getting more serious
now and uh you know she started a
process of converting to judaism and he
turns to me and says well why does she
have to convert to judaism why can't you
convert and i said well actually that's
a really good question nobody's asked me
that question uh but you know we've been
studying and this is you know how we
feel when again he says that's great you
know
i've been in new york real estate all my
life everyone thinks i'm jewish all my
friends are jewish and uh and from that
point he was very supportive and then he
goes into another thing which was funny
that i tell him the book where
he says uh
you know ivanka right now she's in an
amazing place in her life you know a lot
of my friends call they you know they
all respect her he says but you know tom
brady is a good friend and he he's been
dying to take her out
and so i turned him and i said well if i
was here i'd go with tom brady and he
looks at me maybe not maybe getting my
my uh self-deprecating humor or maybe it
was serious and he basically looks and
says yeah i know yeah
and uh so it's good but wow so you beat
out tom brady for ivanka in his version
of events yeah i i don't know it's close
enough to something though that sounds
right uh can you just back up a little
bit and uh explain a little bit more
about some of the stuff with your dad
and how that woke you up and then kind
of changed the course correction for you
because i think that's i think that's a
super interesting part of the story here
sure um so i write about this in the
book as condensed as i can but basically
my father was a major democrat donor new
jersey's a big democrat state
um he was uh involved in a family
dispute as a you know business that he
built up he brought his siblings in
and uh basically uh he was prosecuted
for three years they couldn't really
find much but then he did something a
little
uh maybe a little overreacting uh kind
of to get maybe revenge on them for
causing so much pain to them which you
know human beings make mistakes
and uh he he basically uh sent a tape of
of his brother-in-law who was always
having affairs with a prostitute
and then sent it to his sister just
basically to say screw you and
um and then at the time you know his
lawyers knew about it they didn't think
that it was a crime but he didn't know
that his siblings were then cooperating
witnesses with the government so they
arrested him chris christie was the
prosecutor at the time um
it was he made a big deal of it you know
very ambitious he ultimately ran on to
be you know governor and um you know
after that happened my father i write
about the experience it was very
reflective about it said look i i sinned
before god before man i made a mistake i
let my power go to my head
and um and i i shouldn't have done that
so he took a plea deal and went to
prison for a year
and it was very hard you know his
company was a big company at the time
about a thousand employees
and you know when he left i had to deal
with you know i went to his office you
know five days a week and
uh we had you know great professionals
who stood you stepped up to run the
company but you have a million people
the government was still sending
subpoenas trying to target people
it was very chaotic and then i'd go and
visit him you know every week or maybe i
take a week off every now and then but
try to visit him every week in prison
just to spend the time and my father and
i are very close we ran the marathon
together
and uh and he's an amazing person and so
i think you learn a lot from that
experience that
uh you know one thing he said to me was
you know in life sometimes you're at 10
000 feet you have to come down to earth
to really understand what's there and so
you know i saw very high in life i saw
very low in life and you're going
through that experience you realize that
things can get taken from you right you
know your freedom can be taken from you
uh you know your wealth can be taken
from you your clothes can be taken from
you
and what really matters is just you know
your your friends your health and and
what you do and what you make of the
time you have and so
it was a fundamentally transformative uh
period in my life and i write about
my reactions after and two you know
specific things that i write about are
number one is you know after a couple
days of of spending time with him and
getting that situation as settled as it
was gonna get i go back to new york and
got back to my apartment on mercer
street and i basically just sat on the
floor and i started crying and i
realized that my life had changed and
and i realized there was a lot of things
i was angry at right you're angry at the
prosecutor you're angry at your my
father's siblings for
you know escalating something over money
uh and then i was angry at my father to
a degree and i realized that that just
wasn't productive you know and then i
really made a decision to shift all of
my time and effort towards
trying to be helpful helpful to my mom
helpful to my dad helpful to my siblings
helpful to the company and that was just
a fundamental choice and i think that
that's been something in my life whether
it was some of the challenges in
business that that occurred or even my
time in government any time there was
a challenge a lot of people get very
angry or trying to figure out why it
happened or what they could have done
different i always would just say okay
well it is what it is how do we take the
variables we have and try to make it as
good as it can be and so that was really
you know a fundamental
lesson and i think the other lesson i
learned as well is i finally did my
first day back at at the office at the
da's at the d.a
and you know i would take the six train
down to canal street from astor place
and uh i was going back up and for
whatever reason i just couldn't stand up
so i just stayed on the train and i rode
the train all the way up to the bronx
and back for about it was like two to
three hours and i was just
looking at everyone's faces right you
know you're seeing the people getting on
and off the train and for whatever
reason my mind i was saying
what are they what's their story and i
was kind of making up stories for each
one i was saying well this woman maybe
you know maybe she can't find a way to
you know feed her family or maybe this
guy's about to lose his job or maybe you
know this woman just found out that her
mother has cancer and and so i kind of
realized like
everyone has problems in life and and i
had my problems but you know everyone
has problems and so i kind of said you
know nobody wants to hear about your
problems nobody you know you know just
you got to just do the best with what
you got every day and move forward so it
was a very interesting experience i met
a lot of people in prison um there were
within prison my father actually amazing
people still friends this day
um from different backgrounds some were
bad people some were amazing people who
just made mistakes and so it's a it was
a very interesting
period of life and one that um that
obviously taught me a lot what was it
about the prosecution that that caused
you to have that change and not go that
route did you just see corruption did
you see like an endless goose chase
so i saw you know my father was you know
he was really the leader of our
community he you know anyone who would
lose a job he would give him a job he uh
anytime somebody you know needed a
surgery couldn't afford it he would pay
for it you know anonymously you know he
supported so many people
and did so many good uh so much good
when he was sentenced he had over 700
letters that were sent on his behalf
like each one was more beautiful than
the next about stories that even his
family
didn't know about and
what i saw was that they started
investigating and
then they were looking for one thing and
then it just it never ends and they keep
digging for more and more and there was
an accountant who stole all the
documents who now works for my father's
brother who you know turned it over to
the government and and it just played
out in the press and you know there was
a it's funny at the time one of his
friends said to him there's an irish
thing which is tall buildings attract
lightning um and he was a tall building
and and he attracted lightning i saw
just the prosecutors have unlimited
power unlimited resources and when they
want to dig they'll dig i mean it was a
company that had
uh you know hundreds of millions of
dollars of revenue at the time and
ultimately they were saying okay you you
should have categorized something this
way instead of this way for like a
couple hundred thousand and that was
what he kind of pled to and that's
pretty subjective and usually something
that's that's done civilly as opposed to
criminally so i just saw that you know
christy wanted to get my father he was a
big trophy uh politically for him and he
was just absolutely relentless and
and but again my father
under so much pressure allowed his
motions to get the better of him and
made a mistake as well which was a
lesson for me going through all the
investigations that we ultimately went
through
as well in washington which was you know
if you have good facts like you just
have to be tight be tight be tight and
again people saw i didn't talk much they
saw me accused of all kinds of things
but you know i just i tried to just be
tight be tight be tight just to know
that i i didn't i didn't think my
enemies could defeat me but i knew that
i was capable of defeating myself by
making a mistake and i didn't want to
that to happen yeah it's funny you
turned it to that because as you were
saying that i was thinking boy this this
sort of endless chase and this power
that they have to keep going and going
that does sound awfully familiar to some
things happening happening these days so
obviously it's not what the books about
but just to knock out a little bit of
current events kind of quickly when
you're seeing sort of what's happening
right now the raid and all this stuff
does it ring very familiar to you like
oh we just kind of have power and we can
exercise that power and then we'll
figure out if he did something a little
bit like that a thousand percent like
you saw this with trump and again i
write about in the book what it's like
to be in the middle of that storm and
being accused of treason and having to
spend two years
at some point you're saying like maybe
i'm the one who's crazy right because i
know i didn't collude with with russia i
mean in most days i could include with
trump on the campaign you know or like
the handful of people we had it was a
ragtag campaign and i write about how we
pulled it together and
did that but
then you go to washington you have media
sources that you thought were these like
pristine amazing institutions like the
new york times or the washington post or
cnn or msnbc but every single day and
every single night they're running more
articles or running more stories saying
that oh the the breaking gun uh breaking
news walls
the walls are crashing in and i'd see it
every day and like i'd i'd turn on you
know like rachel maddow at night and i
was like holy cow like people actually
believe this and i write actually you
know schumer used to be a close friend
of our family and he was going around
the upper east side telling all my
parents friends like jared's about to be
indicted he's going to go to jail we
know it for sure we have all the facts
what they did to collude with russia
they were basically denying an election
um yeah but anyways so that was uh
that was definitely it and i see it with
trump now where it's like they tried one
thing it failed they tried the next
thing it failed and then you know he
leaves office and then they uh they
impeach him after he leaves office and
then you know he uh now he's being
looked at by the attorney general even
though there was no
no money lost at all but they're saying
maybe his financial statements are
either high or low or whatever it is and
then uh then they you know run these
prime time hearings basically to say
what a bad person he was and then um and
then you know then they they raid us
home and so you know i i do have a lot
of
feelings that prosecutors left unchecked
with political ambitions and that's why
one of the issues i write about in the
book too is how
because of my experiences i spearheaded
an effort that president trump
ultimately
endorsed and got behind to bring
criminal justice reform and i do think
that
his being so persecuted while he was in
washington opened his heart to
appreciate how unfair prosecutors can be
and what what bothers me a lot is that
all the people who are my allies from
the left
uh against big government overreach and
how unfair prosecutors can be
they were amazing advocates they believe
it but when it happens to trump it's
okay and so
the moral lines are a little bit uh that
they have i guess footnotes to them you
know i think that's pretty much the uh
the definition of trump arrangement
syndrome these people that have this set
of beliefs but when it comes to trump
those beliefs kind of just don't exist
so so going forward a little bit before
you got fully into politics so now you
and ivanka are married donald signed off
on it obviously and you're living a life
in new york city that's not political
particularly right and then the call
comes in okay you're gonna he's gonna
he's gonna do this thing did you
immediately think that you could be part
of it or had value to add or that ivanka
wanted to be part of it or were you
worried et cetera so we didn't know it i
i know this may sound weird but you know
i imagine like most families sit around
and say what should we do this is a big
decision you know i write about you know
we were having uh lunch with uh with
donald for uh for i think it was his
birthday and he says to the kids he says
you know
okay guys i'm announcing this week and
everything's gonna be different and with
him like there was always something you
know so i was like you know and he'd
been flirting with it for a long time
he'd asked ivanka to to write a speech
for him
and actually one thing that was funny
she took him to go see rupert murdoch
because she said look if you're running
you've got to go sit with him
and rupert says you're not running
you're not going to do it
and donald lefney says why was he so
dismissive
and ivanka says look dad you asked me to
introduce you when you give your speech
like i'm still not sure you're gonna
have to announce right and she says look
if you know by the way if you make me
write the speech and get ready and i
give this speech and you get up there
and say just kidding like i'll be pretty
mad at you
and uh and so you know he he kind of
went into it and then we all said let's
see what happens and and the first month
was
just crazy i mean somebody that tweeted
which i saw which was funny where they
said that the last slow news date we've
had was uh june 15 2015 right the day
before the day before the day before the
escalator and uh you know he got up
there and the month after for ivanka was
really consumed with putting out all the
fires right i think trump lost about 30
million dollars in just annual contracts
that were coming in with different you
know vendors yeah and her brothers were
dealing with that
and i didn't really get involved until i
guess it was later on i got donald with
me to a rally and i said you know what
let me see this right everyone in my
in my social circle in new york was
saying this is a joke he's going to lose
but every time that happened like he
kept going up more and more in the polls
and so i thought we were in a very
worldly circle with the heads of the
banks the heads of the fashion industry
the heads of the technology the heads of
the media
and i said well let me just go see
things with my own eyes so i traveled
him to springfield illinois uh you know
we fly on his big 757 you know trump
force one jet
and we're we're going out there and he's
just you know bullshitting like he does
you know talking about the grandkids and
football
and we walk out i have no idea what to
expect
we get into a car go to a convention
center we walk in the gentleman greets
him and says you know welcome mr trump
uh congratulations you just broke the
record for this convention center and he
says well who's the record he says well
it's elton john 36 years ago and he
turns to he says see and i don't even
have a guitar so
we went in there and i also was
surprised too i saw him shaking
everyone's hand and like he was a
germaphobe before it was popular right
to be a germaphobe and so he was shaking
everyone's hand really engaging with
everyone he saw trying to get
information from them
and he gets up on stage for about an
hour and just talks with no notes and
anything and
there's one particular moment you know
he's talking about trade where he was
saying things that were contrary to what
my friends in the upper east side
thought but he gets up there and says
we're going to end common corn we're
going to send it to the states and the
crowd went wild and keep in mind the
crowd was not what cnn told you it was
right they made it seem like it was like
ku klux klan or whatever it was old
young white black male female
um
and so and it just felt like it was real
americans who felt like the government
had stopped representing them and so two
weeks earlier i'd been at a charity gal
in new york for the robin hood
foundation which is one of these great
great groups that does amazing work
and the president of it gets up there
and says the way we are going to create
equality in this country and save
our our country is by promoting common
core and what everyone has to do is call
their senators call their congressmen
this is the policy this is it this is
going to change
i was like okay i guess common core is
good i mean what did i know i was doing
real estate and technology and like i
wasn't you know deep in the policies so
it kind of made me think like wait i
thought all these worldly people knew
what they were talking about why did
these people feel so differently to them
and so all it did was really start my
exploration uh through the process and
then
what did you consider yourself
politically at that point like if you
were sort of having your own wake up
relative to some of this stuff did you
consider yourself like a like a new york
liberal like a like i was an upper west
side liberal i was for for many years
i'm obviously not anymore but did you i
wouldn't say that when i was at harvard
i was probably much more liberal right
that's what you're you're taught if you
take like act 10 with marty feldstein
you know you're basically you know yeah
you know you you have like certain views
of of how the world works i did i did
you know i started off doing kind of
social studies so it was you know
reading a lot of the political theorists
and and um
uh but i through the newspaper we
endorsed obama in 2008 and then in 2012
he endorsed romney because i thought
that obama's policies were very divisive
and i thought that he was terrible with
his middle east uh work uh especially
how he was kind of going to try to do a
deal with iran and and i felt like he
was really weakening the u.s israel
relationship which i didn't like
um
and so i endorsed him and i was very
close with mike bloomberg at the time i
thought he represented probably
he was probably the best embodiment of
my political package so i was registered
as an independent um but probably at
that point very centrist but like i said
it was more
it was it was kind of like this deep
right and i learned to like most people
are actually this deep and one of the
cool things about the books i take
people about through my journey as
somebody who is from that echo chamber
and then went and explored the country
most people
don't get to meet people who disagree
with them and don't engage with them and
and i got to speak with so many people
but i did it with an open mind because i
was having to write speeches at the time
for donald on the campaign
that were representing his points of
view which were points of view that were
different than what i thought was the
right point of view to have so in doing
that i was exploring these things
researching these things
and it opened my eyes to
the fact there's a lot more nuance to a
lot of these policies so then the
campaign's starting and i've talked to
don jr about this publicly on this show
and privately like he was telling me how
so many people that were lifelong
friends that had suddenly deserted him
and just all of that nonsense so now you
and ivanka are intimately involved in
this thing and then he wins now you're
going to dc i mean first off did you
have just a whole bunch of friends that
shed you immediately and how insane was
just getting to dc and then seeing what
that was like so believe it or not we
didn't and i think that what what
happened was i think through my father's
experience
i
was very selective in who i let in so
ivanka and i have a very
uh close relationship and a lot of our
time in new york was spent just the two
of us right if we had to choose been
going to a dinner party or being with us
we would be with us and we would always
love doing different adventures going on
dates you know trying new restaurants
seeing new neighborhoods
and then as we started building a family
that was a priority for us as well and
we'd had a ton of acquaintances you know
from new york but uh but the people who
are our real friends were people who we
thought were very quality people who we
uh got things out of and and i think who
got things out of us and those people
were all people uh mostly on the left of
the political spectrum again i had
probably one conservative friend
that i could think of from before this
experience
but everyone was very respectful and
very very open of what we were doing and
recognized that
again it wasn't ivanka and i who were
you know giving speeches or making
policies it was her father and you know
she was doing what uh what a devoted
daughter uh would do
um but for me i was much more
open-minded and much much more
uh
studying the policies i think for ivanka
she basically said okay if
this is the situation that's happening
she had a mission-driven business at the
time where there were issues she was
advocating for
she said well if i can use this as a
platform to elevate the issues like she
cared about like paid family leave and
and and child care
um she says well then i think it's kind
of irresponsible not to do that so she
gave a speech at the rnc introducing her
father and all the things on the
internet was saying was did she think
she was at the democratic convention
because they were not traditionally
right republican policies
um
i know and that her dad used to be loved
by the democrats i mean there's no
shortage of pictures of with all those
people when they used to love him and he
was donating to some of them
yeah being in new york and again he was
part of pop culture yeah so yeah but but
the short answer is is that you know our
friends were
were really strong and and really still
are and uh what i found is that um when
we
decided to go to washington and i write
about kind of how we made that decision
because it wasn't like we were thinking
okay he's going to win and then this is
going to happen right the whole campaign
was like let's get the goal line plus an
inch like you know who the hell knows
how this is going to work out but you do
talk about that you kind of thought it
was going to happen the whole time right
i didn't again logically it felt like he
should be able to do it right all the
math and i i can go to a whole thing on
polling but
from what i saw was like the polling all
seemed like it was not scientific right
so if you look at all the public polling
that predicted he was going to lose i
was shocked by how many people just
followed it but
polling is basically you call 500 people
and they say yes or no and then you have
to do something called awaiting right
and waiting is basically you say okay
this is what okay we called you know 100
democrats and 100 republicans how many
people who think are going to vote and
then you kind of recalculate the the
results in order to do that so what
happened in brexit right before trump
won was
the polling was off massively now it
predicted the amount of people who said
stay pretty accurately but it was off by
about three million votes for the people
who predicted to leave and as we i
researched why that was i was reading
all the info on it it basically said
that they just under counted low
propensity voters and so with trump uh
all the media was using basically the
obama romney turnout model and i was
like i don't think that's indicative
right like obama had a different
electricity that hillary didn't have and
and trump had a different electricity
that romney didn't have so it felt like
it should be different and then when i
look at we had a data we built a data
file about 10 million people were
showing up trump rallies and a big
percentage of them were low propensity
voters and so we basically every time we
do a sample which we re-engineered the
polling we basically ran it through two
different models one was like the media
model which showed we were gonna lose
and one was our model which showed we
were gonna win and so i just again you
know romney went into election night
thinking they were gonna win if i was
told and then we're disappointed so i
never allowed myself to believe our data
because i'd never done it before and so
but that was what i believed was more
logical as an outcome but we didn't
think about what would come next
sorry it's such a long no no so speaking
of what came next so now you get there
now you're working for the president and
media's not that happy
cnn new york times okay all that stuff
but you guys actually were accomplishing
an awful lot pretty much from the get-go
considering you had no nobody willing to
to work with you yeah so it was a wild
thing and the first year in writing the
book i i went through the first year and
it brought back a lot of memories that
actually were really painful for me
because hey we get to washington so we
make the decision to to it wasn't like
oh should we stay in new york and live
our lives or should we go to washington
was like okay he is now going to be the
president united states
our former lives as we knew it don't
exist anymore yeah right so
and then you say you have an opportunity
to serve in in government
um and try to make an impact and i built
more confidence based on the fact that
in the campaign i was able to achieve
certain successes and things
um that experienced political people
told me was the wrong way to do it but
then i did it that way and it ended up
working
and so i said let's let's give it a shot
and let's try to help him and again
you know he'd never been a mayor never
been a governor so he was running a
family business he was used to working
with family his campaign was a family
campaign
and so we said let's go give it a shot
and and really try to see if we could
help him implement the policies that we
believe in and try to do things that we
believe are good so ivanka gave up her
business to then focus on her mission
i went in
and we had no idea what a brutal world
uh washington was gonna be and so
whether it was like
the
attacks from the media whether it was
the investigation i mean within three
months i have you know people leaking on
me like crazy from inside the white
house you know you talk to yourself and
it would be in the washington post
uh wait can you just talk about a little
bit more about what that's like the leak
situation like how is it possible
because everyone's always talking about
the leaks they were talking about an
awful lot with trump but it happens in
every administration like
did you feel like oh here's
10 people in this room in this meeting
like six of them might be the one or
like how do you manage some of that
stuff as an advisor or do you pull him
aside and say hey mr president maybe
don't or dad in law or whatever you call
him don do you maybe don't say
everything you think off the cuff in
front of everybody because we have this
problem like so so i think i learned and
i think he learned as well you know one
of the funny jokes somebody told me was
they said in washington if you want to
keep a secret between three people two
of them have to be dead right and so
you know but it wasn't quite that bad i
think it was a function of in the
beginning i felt very very helpless
right like i said i think something and
like it would link to the washington
post it was so bad yeah i think with him
too so so a couple things i again i
write about how i adjusted and said okay
the game is the game it's been here long
before me it's gonna be here long after
me you know you have a chance to be in
the game if you are in the game you can
get good things done but you have to get
better at the game and so certain things
like when i would give my opinion to
donald especially when i would disagree
with him i would always do it one-on-one
i would never
say my opinion in front of other people
or i would say something that i didn't
think would be
salacious but when i wanted to strongly
disagree i would always do it privately
because you never wanted to read about
that in the press because that would if
i never wanted division to show between
us because
he always gave me the opportunity to
voice my opinion and sometimes he would
listen sometimes he wouldn't again i was
an advisor
and some things quite frankly i had more
conviction on some things i had less
conviction on and often when he would
ask me i'd say look i'm not an expert on
it let me find somebody who i think is
and bring them in to give you that point
of view
um
but that was probably number one and
then when it came to just dealing with
people you learned very quickly like who
was leaking to which places and right we
just had so many of them who were who
were scumbags who were doing that were
they all your guys
you know what i mean or were they were
they like sort of deep state people that
were all there all the time or where
we didn't have a lot of people right and
and you know the campaign was ragtag
uh we had to staff up quickly or make a
lot of decisions putting different
people together
and uh yeah you just have people and
then you know the more people get
insecure the more they
it's an environment that that kind of
encourages more of it so it's it's a
very
very complicated situation to work in
but like i said i figured out how to
adjust i got tighter
um and then ultimately over time like
towards the end we we announce a peace
deal which we'll talk about later but
like
and nobody knows about it right so so i
learned how to find the people who you
could work with to keep things quiet but
it just took me some time and like when
you work in you know real estate or
technology like nobody's out there
leaking to the press and everyone's
aligned for the same mission too so
it's just a different game and you just
have to learn to adjust to the game
right so all right let's jump over to
the to the peace process so now things
are happening you're a couple years in
you were working on
this
from day one basically
really was it from day one like you said
this is gonna be something i'm gonna get
on did he want you on that was this
something that you just brought to him
so um
the way i found out about it uh was
i get a call from the woman who did uh
public relations for our real estate
business
and at the time ivanka and i were still
thinking will we go to washington or not
and she calls and says the new york
times just called and said you and
ivanka decide to go to washington that
you're working on middle east peace i
said well that's not true i said that we
haven't made a decision he says well
their source is your father-in-law i
said okay so he went there for i guess
an editorial board meeting and they
asked him he saw jared's great he's
going to come and he's going to work on
middle easterners oh that's hilarious i
don't know if he meant it or not but you
know the next stage
who is jared kushner what the hell does
he know about the middle east they were
right i didn't know anything maybe it
was the last time they were right
and um
but then you know after the first couple
months i said okay well this is
something i was tasked with let me let
me start exploring so you know jason
greenblatt came in with me and avi
berkowitz and
we started um we started just
researching what had been done before us
and what i did in the first year was i i
just tried to understand everyone's
perspective on the files so
my biggest deficit was that i didn't
have any diplomatic experience but my
biggest advantage was that i didn't have
any diplomatic experience so i came in
and i give one example in here where i'm
meeting with the ruler of the uae who's
uh thought to be
the most strategic thinker in the region
he's somebody who's been there a while
he just became the president of the
country and he's a guy muhammad bin
zayed who's a was really a giant and i'm
meeting with him
after about six months and i take him
through some of the thoughts as to how i
want to approach it and i i really was
asking him a ton of questions and he
says
i think you're going to make peace here
so why do you say that
he says well the u.s usually sends one
of three types of people to see me the
first types are people who come and fall
asleep in meetings
as the second are people who come and
they basically read me talking points
and have no ability to have a
conversation
the third are senior level people who
come and basically try to convince me to
do things that are against my interests
he says you're the first person who's
ever come to see me from the u.s who's
asking questions
and my fundamental question was very
simple which is the u.s has a ton of
power
um
what would you do if you or us right
like what's the end state that's
achievable here and what levers would
you play with if you or us in order to
try to achieve that end state and it
took him a couple times of me asking
that question to actually understand
that i was seeking like an honest
feedback on the question
but that was how i started with everyone
trying to understand get their
point of view on what needed to be done
knowing that american foreign policy
this is not a knock on democrats knock
on democrats and republicans
basically screwed up the entire middle
east if you take it from
you know allowing even just from you
know the fall of the shah on iran to you
know the the the revolution in 79 and
then you go into obviously allowing al
qaeda to have harbor and and then the
attacks on the u.s and getting us into a
war in iraq and war in afghanistan and
then you have disbanding the army and
then it just it goes on and on then you
know you have isis has a caliphate the
size of ohio they're beheading
journalists they're
they're killing christians uh they're
they're you have uh
them radicalizing people online the san
bernardino shooting the the pulse
nightclub shooting uh syria is in a
civil war half a million people are
killed i mean u.s policy in that region
for decades was absolutely awful and
part of me i guess maybe trump was
saying can't get any worse so give jared
a try right but we thought about it in a
different way and really worked hard and
i write about kind of my journey trying
to understand it for what it was at the
time
instead of being
romanced by the old notions and then the
more i would talk to the people who'd
done it they would explain well this is
what you have to look at and this you
have to i was like that makes absolutely
no sense to me and i was like okay well
if i'm going to fail at least i'll fail
in an original way and doing something
that i think is logical
and i was creamed i mean the new york
times would tell me
all the experts you know on cnn they
would write articles you know saying
that everything i was doing was wrong
and stupid and reckless and going to
cause wars well even as the the
announcements were coming out as the
deals were coming out they were saying
why these are bad deals and it's like oh
they weren't i thought that we all
wanted middle east peace wasn't that one
thing there's a short list of things we
all agree on that used to be one thing
that we all kind of want so did you find
that a lot of the countries actually
were quite willing once
once you made that initial sort of once
you flip the script on them
so
in some ways the entrenchment there was
just as bad as the entrenchment home
right so you think about all these these
critics
and what you have in washington is like
this this class of people who are
basically careerists you know you know
going in and out of washington and then
you have the same people who are
writing about them or from the think
tanks or the the media
and they're also you know so it's like
the same class believe this is what we
call the swamp
and they're they're all vested in not
being proven wrong so they'd rather you
also fail then you'd be proven right and
do it and the whole notion of the trump
presidency was bringing people who are
outsiders to washington
who are results driven you know again
politicians are about process and and
talking points
uh business men are about results and so
we come in with a fundamentally
different approach and and that's the
theme in my book that happens time and
time again right there's two basic cross
currents in the book one is
what it was like to be under endless
attack from you know russia
investigation and impeachment about
trying to you know look into corruption
in ukraine all the media attacks and
that that's one car and i call that the
waves and then you have kind of under
the water where it's nice and calm which
is how did all these policies get done
right how do we get trade deals done how
do we get peace deals done how do we get
deals with congress done we have
criminal justice reform done um and so i
really try to put those two things
together
but that that that complacency was the
same thing i found in the middle east in
the sense that everyone
thought that there were limitations to
what they could do and what i found is
like all these barriers are usually in
people's minds and
and in the region everyone thought it
was fixed and that if there were certain
things you did it was just unsolvable
and you had to go and solve it the same
way
that people before i tried to solve it
and fail or else it's gonna be world war
three and i take people through again i
take them into the situation room
and and really try to give them
the intensity of what's like to make
some of the first decisions right so
trump making the decision to move the
embassy to jerusalem his secretary of
state was against it secretary of
defense was against it the intel
community comes out with assessments
saying that if he does it it's going to
be world war iii and the world's going
to explode and again trump even though
every president for what had said
but then they all got scared away by the
conventional thinking that happened and
what trump did again a businessman
you think about okay that's a risk how
do i assess the risk and then how do i
mitigate the risk and i talk about how
we assess the risk how he mitigated the
risk and how he pushed forward to do it
and at the end of the day at that point
he'd gotten closer with the arab
countries he said look you can't
cherry-pick your relationship with
america iran's your biggest threat i'm
going to work with you on that because i
agree with you on that right that's in
our common interests but don't mess
around on the things that i want to do
israel's a sovereign country they have
the right to determine their capital and
america is a sovereign country and we
have the right to recognize the decision
of another sovereign country and that's
what i'm doing okay and i'm not going to
ask your opinion
and again it was very very intense
because people showed the trump makes
the decision and i really give some
funny stories about kind of the back and
forth and the high stakes of it
but he makes a decision
and then we worked hard to mitigate
and then what happens is the next
morning the sun rises and the next
evening the sun sets and the world moves
on same thing with getting out of the
iran deal people warned him that if you
do this you're gonna have world war
three everything's gonna blow up he
makes a decision next morning the sun
rises next evening the sun sets and he
figured out ways to maneuver and so all
of a sudden everything that seems so
fixed to people
all of a sudden was becoming a little
bit more
of of of of a fluid situation and so
the big obstacle was the israelis and
the palestinians and
you know again as i looked at that issue
and i go through this in the book
that was like seems to me like a fake
situation right it's been one of these
manufactured situations for years and
there's just so much asymmetry and
incentives right the palestinian
leadership was getting rich i mean bibi
netanyahu who runs a military and
economic superpower in israel would fly
to israel he'd fly in an ll commercial
jet abbas who i'm sitting with him in a
meeting like we are he wants a cigarette
he puts a cigarette in his mouth
somebody comes over and lights it for
him like he's a king
and then he flies to washington in a 60
million dollar bbj you know what i mean
it's like it's like the whole thing was
he was rich his family was rich
everyone's doing great but the
palestinian people weren't getting we
weren't getting the love right so we
exposed
kind of
what a bunch of crap that was and how
again the goal of the leader should be
to you know number one provide security
for their people number two to provide
economic opportunities so people have a
better life
um security he did as much for himself
as he did for the people and i have some
examples in the book of ways that we
tested and he kind of was bluffing and
then we call his bluff and he backs off
very weakly
and then we also have situations in
there with um
with economics where we expose that he
wasn't really trying to do that so that
that was kind of uh
what we have in there and that also
allowed the leaders to think differently
than they did before how much more do
you think you could have got done have
there been four more years like were
dominoes really ready to fall i remember
right before the election people kept
saying oh no there's six more deals in
place and there's all this other stuff
we wouldn't even needed four more years
we would have needed six more months and
again i outlined this all for the
incoming administration but you know so
the last deal that we got done and it
was a high-wire deal and i have some
very crazy moments of this in my book
was
after we get uae and bahrain
uh you have sudan and morocco sudan goes
then morocco we get in the lame duck
period which people were surprised and
we were trying to get saudi to go but we
couldn't get saudi or qatar until the
rift was resolved between them so i'd
been working on that for about three
months and we had amazing breakthroughs
in a very intense negotiation
and that one again like literally on on
the tarmac to take off and the deal dies
and it dies several times and these are
complicated situations so that one we
got done jan 5th
which i think opened it up for the new
administration i laid out for them a
road map we were close with mauritania i
felt
i think saudi was very doable i think
now it's a question of when not if
but it needs u.s leadership to make it
happen and so what i basically said to
what the incoming administration is like
look congratulations you guys can get
all these deals done we just we're
running out of clock
but just don't run to iran if you run to
iran you're going to upset everything we
have iran weaker than they've ever been
our policies working just tell iran
you're too busy dealing with climate
change and covid and all the stuff you
you're focused on
and wait for them to come to you
and what i would do is go to saudi
arabia and say look we want you to do a
deal with israel
we'll wait six months we'll wait a year
let's work on a plan together well i
know we said some bad stuff in the
campaign you've been a a country that's
worked with america for 80 years you've
been a great uh ally in many regards
what's going to take to get that to
happen so we could finally end once and
for all the arab israeli conflict
um
and uh
they nodded and then did absolutely
nothing according to that so i think
that we could have we could literally
hand them like a packet did you hand
them like this is what's got to happen
like i didn't write like a memo but i
sat down twice with incoming national
security advisor basically outlined i
said look this is where we are i was
giving full transparency into the
discussions
um but i i i fundamentally believe it
could have happened very quickly um had
they taken a policy but again they they
ran to iran got down on their knees
started begging them i mean iran's you
know trump used to always say iran's
never won a war but never lost a
negotiation
and uh and what they did was terrible
then they started kind of browbeating
saudi which made them say okay let's you
know there's there's other countries in
the world too then they're running over
to china um they they alienated a lot of
the people there and look i think their
recent policy has shifted back right
they went to saudi arabia uh you know
what they did with uae they had uh
missiles shot at their airport from the
houthis in uh
in uh in yemen right so we actually
designated the houthis of terror
organizations they were firing missiles
into two of our allies in saudi arabia
and uae and chanting you know
insignificant statements like death to
america death to israel yeah and uh the
first thing the administration does and
they come in is they undesignate them as
terrorists and then they fire missiles
into uae that land at their airport and
that's like that's like the nerve center
of commerce
and the us doesn't call they're not
restocking their weapons it was a very
very
very very
tense time so i think right now to give
them credit i think they are
understanding that that maybe they
didn't handle it as well as they could
have in the beginning and it does feel
just from what i'm seeing i'm an
outsider now so i don't on the inside
like they're they're trying harder and i
still think that these deals are very
gettable if they if they focus on it in
the right way yeah do you think part of
the problem is that they don't want to
do anything because it'll feel like it's
just an extension of what you guys did
and
they sort of want to erase everything
right they don't want them referred to
as the abraham accords no this is one
thing they've come around on right and
actually they participate in some of the
events we've done to try to promote the
abraham accords it took them a year
right the first year they wouldn't call
it by its name right but i think that
that was high level people i think a lot
of the you know the career folks in the
state department they they were
amazingly helpful in getting the abraham
accords done and implemented and i think
even like you know like dealing with
brett mcgurk he was very supportive so i
think there are a lot of people there
who who want to see it happen um and i
think with the right prioritization it
can i just again i don't know
if these guys have the right ability to
do the negotiation again they're they're
career politicians right they're they're
diplomats like we were the
anti-diplomats right in the sense that
we basically came in and we sat down and
we figured out how to make deals we got
six piece deals done we got major trade
deals done and again i write about how
we did it which again every single thing
in this book that ended up being
effective towards getting deals done are
things that i got criticized for in the
pages of the new york times the
washington post of course of course so
let's talk a little bit about the kobid
situation and then sort of how policy
worked around that because one of the
things that
kind of blew me away the entire time was
that the same people who every day were
calling donald trump hitler and all the
worst things in the world he's a
dictator blah blah blah they were the
same people who wanted him to have all
the federal power to do whatever he
wanted because very early on he was like
let's leave it to the states and let
them figure it out you talk a little bit
about some of the tensions with fauci
and all that how how crazy was that to
advise him uh in in this sort of
unknown moment yeah so that was by far
one of the scariest moments you could
ever have right and and again we
this was after three years and by the
way hypocrisy i figured out is not like
a new thing and why you have to like day
three it didn't take me after three
years you know right um
but um but that was by far the scariest
we had things really moving we were
you know again economy was roaring we
had great people in place we had plans
we were building for second term and
then kovit comes out of nowhere and and
really hit the world like a ton of
bricks and um you know i write about in
the book my experience getting pulled in
again not as a medical expert but just
as somebody to help operationally who
knew how to move the levers of
government vice president pence who i
worked very closely with asked me to
come on and and help him
um you know execute with certain things
like scale testing and whatnot
but it was very interesting so you're
making a lot of uh decisions uh the
media was the first thing they got trump
on right because if he was more careful
than he was killing jobs if he was
opening the economy he was killing
people and so cnn kept those tickers up
you know depending on the day and and
they were loving the fact that they can
just bludgeon him you could always find
a nurse who's afraid they're going to
run out of stuff and we were playing
racquetball i mean i had stories you
know that i write about where i'd see a
nurse on cnn complaining they don't have
masks at a hospital i'd get on the phone
with the head of the hospital and say
what do you need okay we'll get it to
you and we we made sure all these
shortages that everyone was fearing
were gonna happen did not happen a lot
of us because we thought like business
people not like bureaucrats right so i
tell stories about how you know we find
all these masks we figure how to do dpas
and to get them in order to get them
over we don't have enough planes as us
so i call fred smith i call david abney
from ups and fedex and i said look we
need your planes and they're like
they're your air force take them like
anything you do and even david abney
told me months later i've never seen
anything like in my career as quickly as
i could land played in asia you had them
filled with masks and stepped back we
were under a week away from running out
of supplies in this country
and again trump thought out of the box
he empowered business people to do it
and uh got a lot of things done and
ultimately the biggest test with that
was operation warp speed right so even
faunchi said can't no trump is you know
over exaggerating it's going to be at
least a year and a half till we get a
working vaccine and so
we got the bureaucracy out of the way
we brought the private sector brought in
the military
each thing and this is one of the things
i think readers have really liked about
the book so far is that i'm pretty
honest about mistakes that i made and
things that i could have done better but
i showed from all these things how i
learned from these experiences that
enabled us so like the the lessons we
learned on scaling testing was that i
always say to solve a problem there's
three
things you need right you need
imagination you need money and you need
gravity right if those three are
basically the catch-alls of the
categories you need for testing we had i
think a really good plan so the
imagination check that you're the
federal government you print money so we
had endless endless cash that wasn't our
issue right uh but we just couldn't
produce q-tips right basically swabs for
people like you know we're about to
launch 400 sites and they come in and
say sorry we only have 1.2 million swaps
in the country so i'm like
man and i started learning like the
lowest cost item was gonna become our
biggest bottleneck
and
that was just a gravity issue so we we
worked that through and
was actually one of our issues without
cheeks he goes on television and he says
oh
i'm testing we're just not there yet
instead of saying like dude you were in
charge of infectious diseases you didn't
tell us our that we didn't enough
supplies in case one came that you're
sitting in the task force every day
you've given us no additional ideas for
how to do this better if you're on tv
explain we have a plan we're doing it as
fast we can we're going fast in our
elsewhere and say i was like are you a
sports caster or are you a member of the
task force remember what do you make of
him or what did you make of him then and
is that different than now i'll get a
sec but just to finish what i was saying
is that
um
is that ultimately those lessons we
learned from that for warp speed which
is how we did everything right early and
that enabled us to be successful and
ramp up the manufacturing simultaneously
and i give some lessons on that
with him i think that
to
make it for first of all nobody should
be in a job for 50 years
especially not in a government job i
think he was an excellent politician um
in terms of his ability to be a survivor
but i think he also embraced
a lot of the
people would always build these people
up as a counter to trump like
michael avenatti who is now i think in
prison right you know the the media made
him a hero because to be president
because he was against trump right so so
the media would create these like false
heroes and i think with fouchy they
elevated him like they elevated you know
20 people before
and i think he embraced it and i think
he liked it and i think that that led to
a lot of
it wasn't about service and it led to a
lot of misinformation and confusion that
didn't have to be the case and so
again like i give one great scene where
trump is fighting with him saying doc
i'm not going to keep the country close
i'm not going to oversee the funeral of
the greatest country and economy in the
history of the world and he meekly goes
back says look i'm just here to give
medical advice i'm just a doctor you're
the president your job is to account for
all the other factors
and he backed off pretty quickly there
and so
again interesting guy to work with he
was very pleasant you know we had a good
uh working relationship together uh but
very politically calculating and savvy
and uh you know wasn't always on our
team did you feel that from the agencies
in general that the cdc or the nih or
whoever else you were working with that
generally they weren't going to be
staffed with trump people so that there
was an odd incentive structure right
they needed you know they knew an
election was coming
um yes and no look so dr collins at nih
i thought was very professional very
knowledgeable always doing well we had a
couple of tensions with him about uh
getting euas because
they were trying to preserve perfect
science what we're saying like like
slightly convalescent plasma was an
issue where they got killed in the paper
because we were pushing to say this is
something that's been around for 100
years we have a study that's showing
that it's working get it out there let
doctors make the decision if they want
it or not but they're saying the study
which is done by the mayo clinic i think
or cleveland clinic wasn't done in
pristine time so look this is wartime
like if it's looking good let people
make their decisions it's not going to
kill people and that was where we had
some fights with the scientists the cdc
was was an absolute
barn fire mess and you know there's one
fight i had with them where and again i
backed off quickly so i'm saying okay
how's this going to look on the front
page of the new york times and i'm
screaming at the head of the cdc
but they basically were saying this this
14 days rule and i said okay they're
telling our people they have to
quarantine for 14 days as i said maybe
bill where does that come from so we
have a studies i said bring this study
so that night again i was on like two
hours of sleep but i read through the
study
and i'm seeing that it's like
a study of 182 people
of which they know 140 of them got the
disease the average time from contacting
and contracting the disease to showing
symptoms was 5.1 days and because the
sample size was so small they used two
standard deviations and told the whole
world they had to spend 14 days in
quarantine wow you know i'm saying wait
so we're screwing up the entire global
economy off the sample size
of 140 people right it's like so my
point is like a lot of the things they
were saying in the name of science were
not scientific and you know we tried to
be nimble and at first we trusted all
these people because what the hell do we
know these were the experts on
infectious diseases but i think over
time we became
more convinced that we had to be
pragmatic about these things and take
their guidance and their perspective but
weigh it accordingly knowing that there
were a lot of academics who weren't
uh very operationally somebody like dr
burks was actually quite helpful because
she'd been
on the front lines in a lot of these
different countries in africa so when it
came to problems she knew operationally
how to solve them and again i thought
she was a very useful voice i learned a
lot from her
but it was uh it was
very complicated time to be in an
amazing experience
and again i do think the work that
president trump did saved a ton of lives
and i think if you would have had a
normal politician there instead of an
outsider and somebody who had a results
mentality the outcomes would have been
uh significantly different well maybe
this is a silly question but do you
think had the
democrats
media
some of the organizations cdc etc have
they all been willing to work with trump
a little bit more
do you think we could be in some real
golden age right now that so many of the
things that we see with the economy
supply chain just all the nonsense that
we're seeing disaster in afghanistan
that we really did have a chance to to
fix so much you mentioned before that
the the peace deals like there was a
whole bunch coming right there do you
think that had he he was willing to work
with people right
very much so look i think that one of
the things i'm i try to be very honest
about in in my book is that i had
certain biases coming in and my biases
change but we all have biases i think
that
the media today in particular is not
really honest about their biases and i
don't think
people are as liberated where they they
still feel like playing to the standard
of the media is the appropriate standard
by which to try to conduct your your
conduct and ultimately we became
liberated and said okay let's just do
what we think is right
but i do think a lot of these people in
these agencies tried to play to the
media and the media was rewarding anyone
who was in opposition to trump so that
was kind of like the general
playing field again not right or wrong
it's just the reality of what it was
i think from a pure policy point of view
like i said i think i'm more of a
centrist more of a pragmatist in terms
of how i think about these things
a lot of president trump's policies i
thought were spot on right trade right
there was a big debate on trade bringing
our manufacturing jobs back to america
was something that was like
anti-re i mean you know paul ryan was
pissed at us saying you're never gonna
get your usmca trade deal done but my
mentor on that was bob lighthizer who by
the way is i think the best character in
this book people have come away saying
that they really want to meet bob and
and he really is a mentor and a great
friend and hysterically funny um
and i write about how what it was like
working with him but trade was an issue
uh you know immigration right so a lot
of my friends in new york would say well
the wall is xenophobic and racist and
i'd say
okay well maybe that's what they feel
but then you get down you're like well
it's just like a sovereignty issue and
then like you know i talk to the border
agents like oh every mile of wall you
put up we can do you know more and more
and i write about actually how we got
the wall built because that became a
symbol of trump's success and so the
democrats and even i mean steve bannon
john kelly they were supposed to get it
done for the first two years both failed
trump asked me to get done i write about
how we you know found the 11 billion
dollars and i worked with stephen miller
patsy baloney uh chad wolfe mark morgan
you know whole group of people uh russ
vote to figure out how do we get the
money and then how do we get it
implemented and built and so and even on
immigration i think the merit-based
immigration system he was working on is
something that would have kept wages in
america rising brought a lot of gdp
creators to our country and people said
he was against immigrants but he was
wanting people to come to our country
legally and make america vacuum cleaner
for the best and brightest in this world
so that they will
continue to take our country to the next
level so i thought his policies were
really excellent and and to your
question specifically
i do give examples in the book of you
know kim kardashian or van jones people
who were not naturally with trump coming
to the white house on an issue they
cared about both of them took a lot of
grief from people in the liberal circles
i think van was getting called an uncle
tom for you know coming and working with
trump but van did something that they
didn't do i mean he had john lewis
criticizing him for doing it but
meanwhile we got the biggest criminal
justice reform and prison reform bill
done in history of our country and so
you know so i think that trump was
always people who would go and criticize
him on television i always saw that as
virtue signaling and i have no patience
for virtue signaling
but people who want to get things done a
lot of people would work with me behind
the scenes on things some things didn't
get done and those meetings and you'd be
surprised some people are in my office
in the white house you know meeting on
policies and uh and trump anytime
somebody wanted to reach out and meet
with him you'd hear him out sometimes he
would agree sometimes not but i always
saw him more as a pragmatist than
anything else
i think i legally have to ask you so if
let's just say he was to run again and
you get the call again or ivanka gets
the call or it's on speaker phone
how you gonna feel
look i i think that and i'll tell you
what i what i believe right so number
one with trump you never know what he's
gonna do and you never know what's gonna
happen right that's uh that's the only
thing that you can say with certainty uh
number two is i i do believe that
he
is very bothered by what he sees them
doing to this country right you know if
you think about when he left we had
peace throughout the world china was on
their back heel
uh you know we even had to deal with the
taliban i think would have would have
worked out really well
uh no wars in europe economy was getting
ready to explode you know gas prices
were low inflation was low wages were
rising people forget that 2019 was the
first year in 20 that the the wealth gap
in our country started to shrink which
was amazing and that was because people
on the bottom were making a lot more
because of trumponomics so
policies were great but now these guys
come in and and number one is the only
thing that unites them is that they hate
trump right that's why they're raiding
him and investigating him and they can't
stop talking i think biden just gave a
speech you know all about him which is
crazy after he raids his home which is
like again this is getting very close to
like third world country stuff the stuff
that we would be mad at a dictator for
and
but his policies were really good and i
i i wished when they came in that they
would say you know what let's just maybe
talk the way politicians are supposed to
talk and just keep all of trump's
policies and i think they could have
gone down as an incredible
administration but instead they've
chosen to do the opposite
i think for him
he knows that
he could fix things really quickly and
and that's what i think is
is pushing him to want to do something
and whether he makes a decision that'll
be up to him um but we'll see what
happens with that so let's finish up
with something that's not trump related
and not directly dc related or anything
else but uh when i moved down to florida
when we moved down in december i get an
email from you and it basically says hey
heard you heard you're down here in
miami let's get together and now we've
we've become friendly and had dinner a
couple times and you said something to
me the first time that we met that that
has really rung true with me which is
you said something to the effect maybe
you could i'll slightly butcher the
quote and then you can fix it but i
think you said something like if america
is to succeed it starts here in miami it
was something to that effect that
something is happening here in miami and
more broadly florida that that is the
map for the rest of the country now
clearly i believe that you know how much
we're loving it here i just opened these
offices in the studio like it's so
flourishing here
what should people know about what's
going on down here and did you guys
always think you were going to come down
here once dc was done was it immediate
no let's go down to florida miami or did
you want to go how did you even end up
here yeah it was very um it was very
last minute and first of all you know i
was very glad when i saw you move down
because you were a voice that i followed
and i was in the white house and i know
we'd missed each other at one of the the
parties in the white house and and when
i saw you came down i said this is great
you know because florida people are
forming
it's just it's a place where everyone's
helping everyone and so
the decision was like this right we're
we're figuring out what we want to do we
traveled the whole country so we'd seen
all these different places so we'd
identified like maybe two or three
cities that we thought
could be really exciting places to go
new york was out of the question at the
time because it was basically like
pompeii it was it was closed down the
restaurants were closed the schools were
closed uh none of our friends were there
everyone had either gone to the hamptons
or in florida
and um or some people living in aspen
and we basically said you know
this doesn't feel like the place to go
so he said let florida we we honed in on
i joked with ivanka i said look i know
we're about 30 years ahead of schedule
because most old people end up here
anyway
exactly but it felt like a place that
um that had the energy of the future and
so we come down here and we said look if
we don't like it we'll put the kids in
school has a very nice jewish community
then
we'll go back to new york you know in
the fall
we came down and we just fell in love i
mean it just first of all the weather's
great the energy's great what what
really surprised us though was the
people right so
right now you have people from uh l.a
san francisco chicago new york coming
down but you have an original crop of
miamians who are also phenomenal yeah
everyone's coming together when we were
coming up in new york it felt like a
city that had become great over the
previous decades people have fought to
make it
here you have people coming together
trying to create a great city they're
all
uh very invested in doing things
civically socially we've made a ton of
amazing new friends
uh it's i call it sometimes like it's
like freshman year of college where it's
like everyone's like you know creating
new friend groups trying new hobbies
you know when you go to um
you know with your kids you have
activities taking them fishing taking
them boating uh so it's just a very
creative place and what i find is
everyone comes through so what i loved
in washington was that i mean the local
community were like jackals because it's
a one industry town right but the uh the
you always had very interesting people
from business from from uh you know from
intellectual just passing through trying
to influence in one way
here you have an amazing community but
you also have a lot of people coming
through and then what i find is that
it's a very
tolerant place and that you can be at
dinner with people very liberal very
conservative
everyone wants to learn from each other
and i find that it's it's a it's a place
where people don't take themselves too
seriously everyone's doing interesting
things everyone has interesting stories
and the lifestyle's amazing so that
that's been our experience so far i i
know that you're also converted as well
there is nothing that i can possibly say
right now that my audience has not heard
me say about florida
i did i repeat a lot of years it was
pretty much yeah that's it it's pretty
good here that's that's the point and it
must feel kind of refreshing for you
guys in that regard that you're you're
sort of out of the political thing and
then you get to build something in a
place that seems to represent some of
the ideas you were trying to get across
to the country yeah we we don't miss it
and i will say too like you know florida
and again it's been interesting that
it's becoming this big republican
epicenter now the free state of florida
but it's it feels like it's more of like
a freedom driven republican like a no
judgment
uh i think a lot of the future of what i
think conservatism can be uh and again
the one thing i'll say to you i'm very
hesitant to use labels right i learned
that like
we're basically a two-party country
right now but democrats and republicans
like they're each a collection of tribes
more than their like ubiquitous parties
but i feel like here in florida it's
just a lot of uh people doing creative
things and a lot of fun people so it's
it's been a lot of fun to be a part of
it so far
well thank you for coming down to our
local studio here in miami as the you
are the first guest in the local studio
oh you were actually the first guest oh
i guess the studio yes so technically i
was the first guest yeah so i i watched
that one
thank you dave thanks if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell